if we just Linger on the gpt4 system a
little bit
you kind of hinted to edit especially
talking about the importance of
Consciousness in the in the human mind
with homosexions
do you think gpt4
is conscious
I love this question
so let's define consciousness first
because in my experience like 90 of all
arguments about Consciousness before
allowed to the two people arguing having
totally different definitions of what it
is then they're just shouting past each
other
I define consciousness
as subjective experience
right now I'm experiencing colors and
sounds and emotions you know
that does a self-driving car experience
anything
that's the question about whether it's
conscious or not right
other people think you should Define
consciousness differently
fine by me but then maybe use a
different word for it or they can I'm
going to use Consciousness for this at
least
um
so um
but if people hate the yeah so
is gpt4 conscious does GPT 4 have
subjective experience
short answer I don't know
because we still don't know what it is
that gives this wonderful subjective
experience
that is kind of the meaning of our life
right because meaning itself the feeling
of meaning is a subjective experience
Joy is a subjective experience love is a
subjective experience
we don't know what it is
I've written some papers about this a
lot of people have
Julio tanoni Professor has
stuck his neck out the farthest and
written down actually very bold
mathematical
conjecture for what's the essence of
conscious information processing he
might be wrong he might be right
but we should test it
he postulates the Consciousness has to
do with loops in the information
processing so our brain has loops
information can go around and around in
in computer science nerdspeak you call
it a recurrent neural network where some
of the output gets fed back in again
and with his
mathematical formalism if it's a feed
forward neural network information only
goes in One Direction
like from your eye retina into the back
of your brain for example that's not
conscious so he would predict that your
retina itself isn't conscious of
anything
or a video camera now the interesting
thing about gpt4 is it's also one-way
flow of information so if tanoni is
right and gpt4 is a very intelligent
zombie they can do all this smart stuff
but isn't experiencing anything
and this is
both a relief in that you don't have if
it's true you know in that you don't
have to feel guilty about turning off
gpt4 and wiping its memory whenever a
new user comes along
I wouldn't like if someone you did that
to me new realized me like in Men In
Black
but it's also
creepy that you can have very high
intelligence perhaps then it's not
conscious because if we get replaced by
machines
and by the sad enough that Humanity
isn't here anymore because I kind of
like Humanity
but at least if the machines were
conscious they could be like well but
they are descendants and maybe we they
have our values they're our children but
if if tenoni is right and it's all these
are all
trans Transformers that are
not in the sense of the of Hollywood but
in the sense of these one-way Direction
uh neural networks so they're all the
zombies that's the Ultimate Zombie
Apocalypse Now we have this universe
that goes on with great construction
projects and stuff but there's no one
experiencing anything
that would be like
ultimate depressing future
so I actually think uh
as we move forward with building more
advanced AI
you should do more research on figuring
out what kind of information processing
actually has experience because I think
that's what it's all about and I
completely don't buy
the dismissal that some people some
people will say well this is all
because Consciousness equals
intelligence right that's obviously not
true you can have a lot of conscious
experience when you're not really
accomplishing any goals at all you're
just reflecting on something and you can
sometimes um
have things doing things that are quite
intelligence probably without being
being conscious but I also worry that we
humans won't
will discriminate against AI systems
that clearly exhibit Consciousness that
we will not allow AI systems
self-consciousness we'll come up with
theories
about measuring Consciousness that will
say this is a lesser being and this was
like I worry about that because maybe we
humans will create something that is
better than us humans in the in the way
that we find beautiful which is they
they cut they have a deeper subjective
experience of reality not only are they
smarter but they feel deeper and we
humans will hate them for it
as we as human history has shown they'll
be the other will try to suppress it
they'll create conflict they'll create
War all of this I worry about this too
are you saying that we humans sometimes
come up with self-serving arguments no
we would never do that would we well
that's the danger here is uh even in
this early stages we might create
something beautiful yeah and uh will
erase its memory I I
was horrified as a kid when someone
started boiling uh
boiling lobsters like oh my God that's
so cruel and some grown-up there back in
Sweden said oh it doesn't feel pain I'm
like how do you know that oh scientists
have shown that
and then there was a recent study where
they showed that lobsters actually do
feel pain when you boil them so they
banned Lobster boiling in Switzerland
now you have to kill them in a different
way first so presumably scientific
research boil down to someone asked the
lobster does this hurt
survey so we do the same thing with
cruelty to farm animals also all these
self-serving Arguments for why they're
fine and yeah so we should certainly
what the watchful I think step one is
just be humble and acknowledge that
Consciousness is not the same thing as
intelligence
and I believe that Consciousness still
is a form of information processing
where it's really information being
aware of itself in a certain way and
let's study it and give ourselves a
little bit of time and I think we will
be able to figure out actually what it
is
that causes Consciousness and then we
can make probably unconscious robots
that do the boring jobs that we would
feel immoral to give the machines with
if you have a companion robot taking
care of your mom
or something like that she would
probably want it to be conscious right
so the emotions it seems to display
aren't fake
all these things can be
done in a good way if we give ourselves
a little bit of time and don't run and
take on this challenge